we are currently under the topic of
cryptography thank you very much
cryptography all that codes encryption
which is why
we're looking at prime numbers except do
you remember why what the prime numbers
have anything to do
with encryption yes engine the rsa
okay so we had a look at this particular
example
of
ways to encrypt messages right and we
know this is really cool this is a very
clever way of doing it because even if
you know how to encrypt something
you don't at all know how to decrypt
it's much harder and it's all about the
maths of prime numbers okay it's really
easy to put them together very hard to
tease them apart okay so that's why
we're kind of digging into practice now
very last lesson um on friday afternoon
you might remember we looked at some
videos we looked at some interesting
things we did a particular proof for how
many prime numbers there are do you
remember how many there are
there's an infinite number that's right
and um if you can't remember the proof
it's really really very elegant and
short proof it's very very clever um
euclid's proof right
so we learned that there is an infinite
number of prime numbers but what he
didn't answer was how many prime numbers
are there
in terms of like okay for example let's
list out some numbers
so
if i look at the first ten numbers okay
how many numbers are prime
out of the first 10.
i think if i'm counting right
it looks like there are one two
three four four
four primes out of ten right so
well that's not approximately it's forty
percent in this case right that's why i
chose 10
but our 40 of all numbers prime what do
you think do you think it would be more
do you think it would be less
that's a very very good question right
so hold on you're like
we've actually done a bit of thinking
about this right there's an infinite
number of primes
but there's also an infinite number of
well these are the um these are the
natural numbers right so if you wanted
to do a proportion you would divide
wouldn't you
wait
we've looked at infinity enough to know
this is this is a bad idea you don't
want to do this okay because i mean for
starters it looks like it's a hundred
percent
but a hundred percent of numbers and a
prime okay so how many of them like not
just they will be infinity but what kind
of proportion are we talking about for
how many prime numbers there are so
well why don't we have a look why don't
we have we've got 40 here let's do the
next 10. okay so
let's have a look here and by the way
please write down these numbers with me
because we're going to use them in a
second right
this is not just for illustration
all right so i added on another 10 okay
so
how many of these are prime
that's interesting so i've got 40 here
i've got 40
here
so far it looks like it's holding
but let's see what happens you go one
more
okay and now
things do start to change don't they
let's have a look
no no
okay
so you're like oh that kind of dropped
off a bit quickly didn't it 40 40
20 so all up what have i got i've got 10
out of 30. so now it's dropped down to
33
right and you can probably
logic it out think about this right
have a look at the gaps with me
because this is another interesting
piece of maths right
what are the gaps between the prime
numbers okay well look i have a gap of
one here right and then a gap of one
a gap of one okay what's the next gap
i have a gap of three oh okay
so in here i haven't got a gap of i've
got a zap of zero there consecutive
numbers
then what happens you got a one again
you got a three
there okay
uh a one
what happens then from here to here
you've got a three
so you just had ones and threes and then
what happens
you get a string
of five what's the opposite of a prime
number
a composite number five composite
numbers in a row now
think about this right as i go further
what's going to happen to these gaps
they're going to become larger and
larger why is that why do they get
larger
later on okay all right yes we're
starting into it you think about it this
way here's another one think about it
okay think about what these numbers are
in here okay these particular composite
numbers okay
we can do their um their prime
factorizations can't we okay well in
fact i'm just gonna i'm gonna run out of
space if i do all of the trees right um
24
think about it go all the way down
you're gonna fit in you're gonna fit in
two
cubed
times three right that'll give you 24.
okay this guy
and this one here
two squared times seven right now think
about this this is the reason why we got
a longer string and we are going to get
longer and longer runs of prime numbers
uh sorry composite numbers it's because
look at look at what these are built
from okay
clearly these must be built from the red
numbers yes
well the more red numbers you have to
build from
the more composite numbers you'll be
able to make in a row look up here look
up here the reason why you have so few
composite numbers is because you don't
have many prime numbers to build with
yet right look at here
you get to two you get the three it's
like the only thing i've got to build
from are one two and three no wonder i
don't have many options okay
so
these gaps they're going to get longer
and longer and longer so yes the prime
numbers are going to space out how are
they going to space out there's a
theorem for this it's called the prime
number theorem it's a big deal okay the
prime number theorem
it states
how many prime numbers you ought to
expect
under a given number it talks about this
frequency right
so here's what it says
the number of
prime numbers
less than n so you pick pick some number
any value of m
right
and the number of problems you'll find
underneath this number
is approximately equal to
m on
log n now you guys have just learned
what logs are but just to remind you
okay when you see lm that stands for the
natural log that's what this
natural okay so it means it means base e
log base e of n
so what that means is
what power do i raise to
do i raise the power of e2 in order to
get m
okay so i'll give you a quick example um
you guys might remember e is the number
2.7182 blah blah blah we looked at that
so think about this
what would this be
it's it's the number that i have to
raise e to
to get e and that number of course is
one so for example if that's 2.71 that's
2.71 think of it a number you just do a
bit of a guess it doesn't have to be
exact what would you expect this to be
equal to roughly
what number do you think you'd have to
raise e to in order to get as an answer
nine two one
it'd be between two and three right
because this is if you call that if you
go approximately actually is it between
two and three yeah yeah it is right if
you call that approximately three you'd
have to raise it to the power of two to
get to nine wouldn't you
um but of course this is not quite three
it's a bit lower than that so you can go
for your calculator now and i'd like you
to get it out actually nice
log base eve nine so you can just go
straight to the um natural log button ln
you should have a buttons just for that
and go log nine so you get two points
2.19
okay so as we said it was between two
and three right
so what you can do
is and i said this is approximate right
because you're going to get a decimal
out of this let's try this for nine
let's try this for nine
okay
so what is
what is nine over log nine well you just
worked out what log nine is right so do
nine divided by log one that should give
you a decimal what do you get
four
four point something yeah 4.09 4.09 okay
well let's have a look
here's nine right how many primes do i
get under nine answer one two three four
now
it's worth mentioning and you can go
ahead it's not it's not that hard to try
it out this is part of the reason why i
asked you to write out these numbers
with me right
if you pick any arbitrary number okay
it's not always conveniently so close to
that okay for instance if you try say
26 let's just try it okay so if you go
26 over log 26 what do you get 7.98 7.98
so you're looking at close to eight
right but we know there's actually this
is the ninth one so you're not quite on
right but like i said
it's approximate
and for greater values of n the bigger m
gets the closer this will get okay so if
m was like a million how many prime
numbers would there be less than a
million well actually why don't we go
ahead and work out because i don't want
to go ahead and write them
so there's a million over log a million
what's it equal to
um
72 000.
um 380.
382 points something
exactly sure
all right now just a quick question
we said forty percent
still forty percent at this point we
were looking at 33
because it was one in three okay so
what's this
way less right how many if it's 72 000
out of a million
okay so what we were predicting that
these gaps would get bigger and we'd
have less and less prime numbers that's
borne out by this theorem okay 7.2
and i guess as we continue right you'd
get less and less unless if you're
curious why it's because of this guy
down here some of you might have had a
look at this
this is what the graph of the
log function looks like and it tapers
off it gets it's it's still increasing
but it slows down it slows down you can
think of that a little bit like
the prime numbers they're slowing down
i'm getting them less frequently as i
keep going
an odd number that's a good question
i'll let you have a think about that i
haven't written them up
hold on pause for a second i'm going to
pose that question to everyone because i
think we have enough information to
answer it okay the question was
we have rows of 10 right
oh you turned
lucky you i have very good aim i would
pitch in
we have rows of 10 here
the question that was posed was well any
of these rows if i kept going will any
of these rows end up having no primes in
them i think we know how to answer this
and how what do you reckon brendan well
if by 100 million there's about 7 in
every 100
it means that there's ten rows and seven
prime numbers so that has to be
somewhere okay
see if you followed that because that
was exactly right okay use this logic
here right not not straightforward by
even after it's explained to you you're
like
um
this is saying by the time we've counted
to a million
on average seven percent of the numbers
will be prime okay don't forget by the
way according to this very small sample
we've seen they're going to get less
frequent right which means that actually
if i took say like the last section like
you want to do an average here right
this is across the whole population we
know early in the population the primes
are quite frequent right so in order to
make this an average that have to be
even less frequent than this by the time
you're getting to the end of the list
right
but let's just say it was seven percent
okay that means i'm going to have 10
rows here and on average there will only
be seven of them that are prime out of
the 10 rows that's 100 numbers right so
clearly seven primes across 10 rows i've
got to at least miss three of the rows
right and in fact i probably missed more
than that
make sense
okay good so the primum theorem it gives
us all of these weird cool insights and
proof for it unfortunately it's a bit
mathematically involved so i'm going to
leave us off that but
this is what's interest